hello everyone this is Round seven of
the isle of man open international
tournament and magnus carlsen drew his
game against weeded Santosh Qasim is
still holding first place with six
points and with it Santosh is sharing
second place with Mo Sadowski and
Fabiano Caruana and Fabiano got to this
five and a half points by defeating
British grandmaster and chess order
Gwaine Christopher Jones and it's a
pretty theoretical game it was well most
of it was home preparation but it was
not without excitement so let's see this
beautiful game played between these two
top players Khurana is white and he
plays efore we have e5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 so the Ray
Lopez we have a six bishop to a 492 f6
Kawara castles b5 Bishop to b3 Bishop to
be a c5 c3 d6 on our a four rook to b8
we have d4 Bishop to b6 and here Khurana
plays a5 and mr. Jones plays Bishop to
e7 but what's the idea here why can't
black capture this pawn on a five well
if Knight captures on a five you get
white has this option of playing rook
captures on a five and after Bishop
captures on a 5d captures on e5 now
attacking the knight and well if you
recapture the pawn with D captures only
five you get Queen Catorce and e8 with
check King captures and Knight to e5 and
this is well where blacks problems are
west thread is Knight to c6 attacking
the rook on b8 and also the bishop on a5
and if black prevents this with Bishop
to b7 you get Knights to f7 with check
so the King has to move and you don't
capture the rook immediately since your
knight is protected when f7 and you
don't want to allow black to grab this
pawn on e4 so simply push if he 5 Knight
has the Moon Knight e4 and now you
captured the rook and rook captures
night and for example Bishop d3 here and
it's a much more enjoyable position for
white so
Jones didn't want to go for this and
after a five he played Bishop to a seven
we have h3 not allowing any g4 ideas and
now Jones castles we have Bishop to e3
rock back to a8 probably what idea is
that if Caruana goes D five that this c6
Knight can move so this Bishop on a7
would be protected rook to e1 we have h6
flat B D to e capture Sundy for C
captures on d4 and knights to be four
and now we have a five-night F to d5 we
have night today the Knights three four
and now Knight captures any three rook
captures any three and Bishop to b7 and
it seems well Jones's bishops on a seven
and b7 are very nicely placed both
eyeing that King side very nicely but
karana plays east six now and well you
don't want to capture this c6 bone
allows Bishop captures on e6 so instead
he plays Knight to d5 now blocking this
bishops protection of the pawn and also
attacking this rook on e3 so karana
first captures he captures on f7 would
check we have King to h8 and I wrote a
one getting rook out of harm's way
and now rook captures on f7 and rook the
c1 wrote the c8 now developing the rook
and also adding protection to the c7
pawn and well here Caruana plays Knight
F to G five and this is why the title of
the video is called it helps to know
that you're winning because all the way
to here karana probably had all of this
in his home preparation and well the
strongest move for black here is rook to
e7 but mr. Jones played the rook to f5
and here well Carano knew that he was
winning here but he didn't know the
exact response to disrupt f5 idea of
course you don't want to capture the
night with H capture some g5
because Queen to h5 check King g8 and
all night capture some g5 threatening
checkmate on h7 so for example g6 and
now you get Queen - h8 check King
captures Knight captures an F
we'll check for king the king and queen
after king moves well you lose the Queen
and white is up the exchange and winning
completely so after this night the g9f
to g5 idea we have rook to f5 and well
here we have Knights to e6 a very nice
idea attacking the Queen and after Queen
37 point to g4 and what are Jones
options here can you capture this night
here on e6
well if Queen captures on e6 you get
night to g3 and well this opens up the
attack from this rock on e1 to the Queen
and e6 and also now there's a double
attack on this rook on e5 from the
knight and the Queen so well you don't
really have anything here to play as
black you can place for example rook t5
and not simply D captures on e5 well a
winning position for white and after
Queen to g4 you don't capture with Queen
captures only six for example maybe we
want to play rook to f7 adding more
protection to this g7 well
koonta g6 makes it very hard for black
to play this game for example rook to f8
and now Bishop to c2 and now there are
all sorts of well crazy ideas because
after this knight on e4 moves Queen to
h7 check a quintet 7 checkmate is coming
so after something like Knight to e7
attacking the Queen now you can capture
Knight captures on f8 and after Knight
captures Knight captures Queen rook
captures night-nights to g5 and the well
again it's a very unpleasant to play
this if a chapter 75 Bishop captures and
g6 not threatening checkmate with rook
to e8 and after you defend this rook to
d8 you simply captures rook captures on
c7 and the black loses a piece here so a
very uncomfortable uncomfortable
position for black after this going to
g4 move so Jones tried Queen to f7 and
now we have rook to a rook to c7
now attacking the Queen rook has
captured rook captures on c7 and now
karana doesn't capture the rook but he
plays Knight captures on d6 and well
black is holding on by a thread here his
queen is attacked on f7
rookies attacked mf5 his other rookies
attacked here on c7 his bishop is
attacked on b7 this bishop is attacking
the knight on d5 and also eyeing that
Queen mf7 this is a well a very very
unpleasant position for black to play so
Jones plays the only probably active
move he has he plays rook captures on f2
but now he gets Knight captures on c7
and well you can't really capture the
night with the night because you lose
the Queen here on f7 and well if you
play Queen captures on c7 you get rook
to e8 check King to 87 and now Queen to
e4 with chick and after g6 well Bishop
captures on d5 and you don't want to
recapture the bishop because after Queen
captures on d5 well this Queen to g8
checkmate is pretty much unstoppable
so after for example Queen key after
some b6 you get Bishop to GA to check
King the g7 and now Queen captures here
with the check King to f6 and yeah f h4
and the well stopping Queen to f7
checkmate is well something what simply
cannot do what he could play something
like King get five but now country for
check and after King to f6 rook check
captures the Queen and after the King
moves simply King captures rook an f2
with Queen to f7 checkmate to follow so
after night to c7 capturing this rook
John straight Queen to f6
we have Knight d5 capturing the night or
now Queen to d4 threatening discoveries
when the rook moves but of course Queen
captures on d4 is played Bishop captures
on d4 namibian threatening some
discoveries but Caruana finds a very
nice refutation he plays rook to e4 and
now there are Doron really on training
her discoveries when this rooks moves as
this rook is also attacking the bishop
raimondi for and well mr. Jones has a
problem he's a piece down so
Bishop to a7 is played and now karana
plays Knight to b6 and in this position
mr. Wayne Christopher Jones resigned the
game and the Caruana
is after seven rounds in the Isle of Man
national tournament tied for second
place with five and a half points and
because you don't really have anything
to play here if you go Bishop captures
only for simply King captures on f2 and
you're down a whole piece and if you
even try something like rook capture
some b2 so now if white captures Bishop
you capture his Bishop on b3 first you
get rookie a check and after King h7
Bishop to g8 with check moving the
bishop out of b3 and after King to g6
not capturing this bishop and what not
white is up to pieces this is this is
completely winning for white so after
this night to be six move mr. Wayne
Jones resigned the game and the world
it's a very nice game especially if for
a rule opus game so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon